aux etats unis bill clinton engagé la
grande bataille politique de sa
présidence la réforme du système de
santé chantier immense en effet pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de sécurité
sociale aux états unis et environ 38
millions d'américains ne bénéficient
d'aucune protection contre la maladie
reportage de notre correspondant à new
york bruno alba
les américains sont malades malades de
leur système de santé à la télé tous les
soirs ces publicités propose des remèdes
de cheval contre la grippe les maux
d'estomac tous les bobos souvent sérieux
qui rendent la vie impossible et
empêchent de travailler un marché en or
dans ce pays où 37 millions de personnes
n'ont pas de polices d'assurance maladie
au supermarché de la médecine on ne se
soigne pas en tue la douleur et sans la
compétence du docteur pourtant les
américains ont des médecins est sans
doute parmi les meilleurs du monde mais
trop souvent faute d'assurance maladie
ils n'ont pas les moyens de prendre
rendez vous résultat ce système peut
transformer un mal de gorge banal en
désastre financier et wade le patient
attend n'a pas accès aux soins tombe
malade attrape une pneumonie arrive aux
urgences et fini par coûter 42 mille
francs au lieu de 60
bill clinton propose au congrès de doter
tous les américains de cette carte en
laquelle il voit le grand remède contre
l'injustice et la gabegie financière
elle garantirait à tous un accès
automatique à la médecine la moins
coûteuse celle du généraliste il clinton
sait qu'il joue son avenir politique sur
cette réforme et c'est sa propre femme
qui l'a chargé du dossier
80% de la facture à la charge des
employeurs 20% à celle des patients
déductibles d'impôt simplification de la
paperasserie règle d'or mieux soigner
soigner plus tôt et pour moins cher
le système
fonds 14% de l'apn v de l'économie
américaine et à croître à deux fois plus
vite que l'inflation générale du pays et
donc c'est absolument nécessaire de
stopper cette hausse qui est inabordable
pour le pays des américains approuvent
les patrons se demandent s'ils pourront
digérer la facture les mauvais esprits
du congrès trouve étrange que l'on
puisse soigner mieux en dépensant moins
et avant de voter quoi que ce soit ils
passeront longuement à la loupe
l' ordonnance du docteur clinton